l'année 2020 avait plutôt bien commencé
pour pascal goupilleau le 1er janvier il
lança société en cubes et au ski cube
une plate forme de recommandations pour
les artisans du btp prévu pour le mois
d'octobre
on avait prévu de lancer début septembre
donc avec le co vide on a pris un peu de
retard dans les développements
on a pris un peu de retard aussi pour
rencontrer les clients qui étaient pas
très visible sur cette période là
qu'avaient d'autres choses à penser
pascal goupilleau envisage de faire
appel au fonds résilience pour
poursuivre son développement
un prêt dont a bénéficié cette
plateforme d'accès aux services de
maintien à domicile
cette start up a connu pendant le coït
des factures de clients paient
heureusement que ces aides étaient là
parce qu'aujourd'hui on n'aurait pas pu
continuer justement ce travail qu'on a
poursuivi on n'aurait pas pu continuer
de payer nos fournisseurs on aurait
ralenti l'activité
donc on a eu une recours notamment au
pge aux prêts garantis par l'état
le ski cube accueille actuellement une
vingtaine de start-up si l'établissement
saint quentinois note leur bonne santé
il a continué à les accompagner pendant
le confinement
l'ensembe start up a dû
regagner les missiles et nous avons
évidemment gardé contact avec avec elle
mais que ce soit de contact avec les
startups évidemment que nous incluons à
skis cube mais aussi avec tous les
porteurs de projets de l'agglomération
ont mis en place un plan de relance
démobilisé évidemment ses propres fonds
pour accompagner de manière
complémentaire des entreprises qui par
ailleurs n'aurait pas pu forcément
bénéficié des fonds mis en place un plan
de relance de 2 millions d'euros le ski
cube n'est pour le moment pas totalement
déconfit nez les projets se préparent
sur rendez vous